okay so getting into Titans made in
Manhattan uh this story is amazing but
this is actually a story really for like
a lot of you old Titans fans mostly guys
who've been reading Teen Titans for
years and years and years and years
especially in classic DC before the new
52 and the reason why is because this
actually takes a lot of the concepts
from titans han and then expands on
those two guys who don't know when new
52 launched the Titans were non-existent
and that was kind of a big deal for a
lot of people because the Titans was
basically the grown-up Teen Titans it
was the original Teen Titans team plus
or minus a number two that it basically
grown up and formed a team of their own
just called the Titans and then it set
the stage for a new generation of Teen
Titans to be brought in to craft their
own little niche in the realm of
superheroes but when the new 52 launched
you had a reiteration of Xtreme Titans
that not very many people liked and you
didn't have the Titans so the question
that people had was what's going on
where are the Titans and so what DC did
is they wrote a story called Titans hunt
that was designed to go back and
basically say here is the story of what
happened to the Titans here's a story
what happened to the Teen Titans yadda
yadda yadda you know kind of bring those
things in and add that stuff to the fold
now it was really like a limited run and
it was designed to be a story kind of
told in the past and sort of expand on a
few things but one of the things that it
did is it actually introduced or kind of
reintroduced in the new 52 the
characters of Karen Beecher and Malcolm
Duncan now the reason why they matter is
because of the fact that they were
members of the team Titans even if only
for limited capacity before the new 52
and they don't play a wildly significant
role in the overarching DC landscape but
they do play a pretty important role
here and again this is really just
designed by DC for the purpose of kind
of going back and touching on a lot of
these old things that were never really
expanded on in the realm of the new 52
kind of reminding you know traditional
you know classic DC fans a lot of that
classic DC stuff is still there and
especially being reworked in a way that
they remember it now the reason why I
say that is because of the fact this
initially picks up with Malcolm Duncan
and Karen Beecher at a place called meta
solutions now Malcolm Duncan basically
had an ability that I believe dealt with
sound manipulation and what we end up
finding out here is that in this VC
rebirth landscape that Malcolm Duncan
has essentially gotten rid of his powers
that for the most part he just didn't
really like having them he didn't really
know how to control them but the basis
behind him getting rid of his powers was
actually a result of his experience with
a villain named mana
who was part of the fearsome thought now
the fearsome five was a team that was
introduced back in the 1970s I think
maybe in the 1980s I think they were a
new team tightness group but they were
the arch enemies or at least one of the
many arch enemies that the Teen Titans
had but it was literally just five of it
originally they were led by a villain
named dr. light but eventually dr. light
was defeated and the villain that we'll
see here Simon
took over the team so it's basically
grabbing the original fearsome five from
classic DC and then bringing it over
into DC rebirth and then essentially
saying here's everything you remember
with regards to the fearsome five and
how they function now with the whole
idea of meta solutions they're basically
an organization that exists for the
purpose of either giving people powers
or taking powers away from people but a
lot of it really seems to be willing in
terms of people who lose their powers
they go there and say look I don't know
how to use my powers effectively meta
solutions will offer them the
opportunity to train on how to use their
powers and if they refuse then meta
solutions will just take their powers
away if that's the option that they want
it's literally you going there and
saying look I have these crazy powers
you know I have telepathy but I can't
control what mines I read I don't want
to have to worry about it and meddlesome
meta solutions will take those powers
from me now of course that begs the
question where do those powers go hence
the nefarious side of meta solutions but
Malcolm Duncan and basically given them
up and you know given up his sound
manipulation abilities and is brought
Karen Beecher there as well now of
course the two of them were a couple
they have a daughter together so on and
so forth but the idea is that Karen has
powers of you know super speed and
strength and so on but you can also
increase and decrease her size and so
the idea is that she's considering
giving up her abilities as well now of
course the person who's running the show
here at meta solutions is a guy named
Simon this is kind of a funny thing
because there was one video that I did
with the Titans Idol number if it was
like the annual or if it was a one-shot
or something like that but I kind of ran
over this character of Simon I didn't
realize he was as old as he is Simon
goes all the way back to like 1970
something and he actually got his powers
from trigons I was basically trying kind
of messing with his head and giving him
like these insane powers of telepathy
and telekinesis and so on now I believe
that he's been reworked over the years
but as far as I'm aware this goes back
to that original origin now it doesn't
tell us it doesn't like do have any
dignity with dragon in the story it's
never reference never talked about but
the indication especially when he's
dealing with with omen dealing with
lilith clay the titans resident psychic
when he's talking to her he actually
kind of talks about how his powers are
unlimited
more or less
would indicate that he's still very much
rooted in a whole origin up trying which
they may or may not expand on at some
future point in time but again right now
the Titans are still kind of dealing
with the idea that they were a team
again because remember the Titans are
kind of coming back together and
remembering everything for the first
time they're remembering that they were
a team at one point in time the you know
Wally West the classic Wally West has
reappeared sort of awakened them to the
truth of who they were before you know
and so they're basically kind of
remembering what they're about to do
expanding on their own weaknesses and
strengths for example when it comes to
Garth you know the original Aqualad he's
a guy that's been trained you know by
the Atlanteans in a multitude of
different title you know styles of
martial arts some unique and some known
across the world whereas Lilith is a
psychic and so she's not really used to
hand-to-hand combat but she's learning
hand-to-hand combat in the first place
when it comes to Donna Troy
traditionally in some form or fashion
basically created as a clone of Wonder
Woman you know depending on exactly how
it is they choose to do it IDC is still
in the process of fleshing out her
backstory going through and essentially
leading up to a point where they retell
her origin again of course is also
classic Wally West coming to grips with
the fact that he's now you know he's
back he's among his superhero friends
and trying to you know trying to
acclimate to this environment to this
world that he's in now of course again
for the character of Malcolm Duncan
while he's still at meta solutions he
actually has his flashback when he sees
mammoths and mammoths again as a member
of a fearsome five was a guy who almost
killed Malcolm and so with this whole
thing Malcolm initially kind of freaks
out and takes off because this is just
PTSD this is him kind of going back and
remembering those that moment when he
was almost killed and there's almost you
know completely overwhelming for him and
so in response to this little clay you
know omen basically picks up on the
psychic backlash of Malcolm Duncan and
his struggle to comprehend what's going
on and it draws the attention of the
Titans themselves now what this tells us
is that there's a connection between the
Titans and Malcolm that's how we know he
was a member of the team at one point
along the line these connections are
formed and they never go away even if
they just kind of sit in the background
even if they're never really used
anymore there's just still that
connection that's there as part of the
team and that's really the way the Teen
Titans always worked and when you had a
psychic member on a team they were very
similar to how the Justice League worked
right like when the Justice League goes
out on a mission and Martian Manhunter
is part of a team Martian Manhunter
would be the psychic linchpin which
means there would be like some major you
know that they would all get together
and say okay guys like there's all these
major catastrophes going on he
one of us will go out and deal with each
one of these catastrophes and Martian
Manhunter will stay in the watchtower
and he'll be the guide that will keep us
all connected we'll know what the other
person is doing so if Wonder Woman's
overwhelmed or Superman's overwhelmed or
that man's overwhelmed the other members
of the Justice League can respond the
psychics regardless of who they are on
the team Titans you know and with omen
as part of the Titans
serves the exact same purpose and so
again because of the fact that Malcolm
had been part of the Titans at some
point along the line he's basically able
you know he's still kind of connected to
them even on a psychological level and
so again he basically explains
everything that's going on with regards
to Simon with meta solutions so on and
so forth and the Titans respond
accordingly now again when the Titans
arrive here on the scene there
immediately skeptical and the reason why
is because this is effectively the
fearsome five that's basically come
along and said oh hey we're doing good
things here we've reformed ourselves
we're not bad guys anymore you know some
of us have given up on giving up our
powers those of us who haven't have
reformed ourselves but we are on a
mission of mercy we are here for the
purpose of training people to use their
powers adequately now this is kind of
cool because this is actually the
perfect route if you were a bad guy what
better way to make yourself off as a
good guy than to help other people so
again it's a really cool kind of
scenario here I mean it's absolutely
great the way it really unfolds and it
really kind of begs the question is it
true and in fact Simon goes as far as to
have omen basically read his line and
say am I telling the truth or am i lying
and omen confirmed but he's essentially
telling the truth and so because of this
the Titans while they are a little bit
skeptical ultimately end up leaving with
Karin just because of the fact that you
know Karin learns about MANET having
almost killed Malcolm and then just kind
of takes off on meta solutions but the
crazy thing about this is that meta
solutions is almost like a drug right
like I made for Karen Beecher she was
never really able to control her powers
she was never really able to control her
abilities and so being offered the
opportunity to be able to do that to
basically have the best of both worlds
to have her powers and be able to
control them it's almost like a drug
that she can't resist and so because of
this she's still very much in flux she's
still very much in turmoil trying to
figure out what direction she should
choose now with the rest of the Titans
sitting down and really kind of
analyzing everything that's going on
with regards to the fearsome five this
is when we get a little more of an
explanation on Roy Harper now in truth
if you've been reading DC Comics for any
real measure of time what you see here
is not anything you didn't already know
but for new fans this is all new stuff
once
Harper was the original sidekick of
Green Arrow Oliver Queen
and then the story snowbirds don't fly
as part of Anil Adams and Dennis
O'Neill's run on his character they
basically started delving into more
realistic things and one of the things
that they revealed was that Roy Harper
was addicted to drugs now of course this
led into this sort of Reformation for
his character and DC was able to delve
into the real psychological impact if
the actions that we had on not just
himself as well as you know the other
members of the superhero community and
those who were closest to him especially
Green Arrow what just did is it allowed
me to kind of go forward and focus a
little more on things but the argument
devoid Harper makes is that where he was
able to clean himself up it didn't
happen overnight it didn't happen in a
matter of weeks but a few weeks ago the
fearsome five were facing off against
the Justice League a group as evil as
they were as bad as they were doesn't
just suddenly reform overnight it takes
time it takes a lot of rebuilding it
takes people to talk to it takes friends
it takes all different kinds of things
to overcome this kind of scenario and so
immediately while we're in Harper is
like look I can't prove it if we go
through and start poking around so I can
almost guarantee you we're gonna find
that the fearsome five are up to no good
they are basically bad guys and that's
exactly what happens here but that's why
this is so cool right like that's why
the Titans are so cool and this is one
of the things we talked about in our
Teen Titans video you know in our Teen
Titans video we talked about the idea
that the Teen Titans serve the purpose
of kind of creating this connection with
a lot of teenagers in terms of teenage
struggles and you know love and romance
so on and so forth with the Titans it's
more adult-oriented feet it's the idea
of their past experiences as Teen Titans
molding with how they view the world as
adults and then from there sitting down
and saying okay how can we reshape and
how can we tell these stories in a way
that make them tangible so that those
people who were reading Teen Titans as
teenagers can carry that experience on
and basically kind of continue the trend
as if there was no stopping point they
saw the world as teenagers now they see
the world as adult the Teen Titans are
the Titans here they saw the world as
teenagers when they were Teen Titans now
they see the world as adults when
they're Titans and the theme the
connection remains between the reader
and the comic and so it's really kind of
cool in terms of how all that comes
together and in terms of how all that
works now forced with classic Wally West
and Dick Grayson kind of poking around
meta solutions things progress exactly
as we would expect and the fearsome five
basically make their appearance - like
haha
of course we're bad guys and mammoths
shows up now forced one thing to keep in
mind with mammoths is despite his you
know brute strength his incredible
strength his incredible durability he
was never the sharpest tool in the shed
I mean the engine was running but there
was nobody behind the wheel and with his
character it's still very much the same
way he's not a thinking man's villain he
is a go here do that kind of villain you
know he's really good at doing what he's
told and that's really about it the
other half of this is that when Malcolm
you know goes to get a drink for himself
and Karen back to Titans Tower when he
comes back he ultimately finds it
Karen's gone which of course leads to
the idea that Karen is basically racing
off to go you know join the Titans and
try to keep them from being killed and
so on and so forth now of course this
eventually leads to care and making her
appearance as well as the remainder of
the Titans Roy Harper and Garth and Dawn
and Troy and Lilith basically rescuing
Dick Grayson and and Wally West but this
is only started to get into different
elements of the fearsome five what
they're capable of Jenks lives up to her
name state probability manipulation able
to basically manipulate the likelihood
that something bad will happen in this
instance is the necessity of being able
to access something you know well she
can manipulate probability so that the
lock symbol just won't unlock or
whatever the case may be it's one of
those weird kind of Magic's where it
borderlines on reality will be it's a
very difficult power to write and
characters like that aren't written very
often because it's a very fine line
between I'm going to make it so the door
is unlikely to unlock or you're unlikely
to win the lottery and I'm going to
manipulate reality so that you do win
again it's a very fine line between how
those things work the fact remains here
with regards to Simon again kind of
getting back home with this idea of him
you know his relation to try again you
know the unlimited unbridled power of
his telepathy and telekinesis this comes
home to roost when he's facing off
against omen and as powerful as he is
you know he said look like I can sense
how powerful you are and you're a very
very powerful psychic very powerful
telepath but my levels are unlimited I
just keep going and going and going and
so because of that this again hits home
at the idea that Simon's power is not
just a result of you know some
experiment or something like that it's a
result of him gaining his abilities from
some godlike being which of course you
know when the the pre-crisis landscape
turned out to be a try ganor maybe it
was a post-crisis I can't remember but
regardless he got his powers from Trigon
now of course with regards to Charon
jumping in Charon faces off against
various members of the fearsome five it
actually holds her own
takes every last one
in the mouth and uses all of our powers
to do so the problem with this is that
she's ultimately defeated by son but
instead of simply just knocking around
what he does is he actually strips away
a section of her memory he literally
just takes this portion of her mind away
and the result is that she does not know
who Malcolm Duncan is and she does not
remember that she has a child all she
knows is that she's just a woman in the
world trying to make her way and that
kind of a thing so again it really shows
us the impact that people with psychic
powers have on those who cannot defend
against them but really the the big kind
of cliffhanger to this the big kind of
cliffhanger to this story comes in the
fact that Wally West and Dick Grayson
had actually managed to hack two
computer files of medicines and found
out that they were one of a multitude of
corporations that are being backed by a
group called hive now the reason why
this matters is because of the fact that
hive actually plays a role within the
Deathstroke landscape which is why this
is effectively a prelude to the Lazarus
contract because hive is an organization
that really just kind of looked at the
idea of world domination and artificial
human evolution and what better way to
implement artificial human evolution
then to take and give people super
powers then to literally be the one who
decides who gets to be God and who
doesn't and so again it's really kind of
a cool scenario with regards to how that
unfolds but what we also know is that
one of Slade Wilson sons Grant had
somehow been involved in hive and ended
up dying in the process we don't know
how far back that goes we don't really
know what his involvement was we simply
just know that was the case but what
this does is it creates a linchpin
between the Deathstroke comics and the
Titans and Teen Titans comics and sets
the stage for the main Lazarus contract
story but that being said guys if you
are new here to come this explain where
she got the sub button to become part of
the Rob force you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and yeah
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]